うううーー do
みなさんこんにちは
じゃ
今日私が伝えたいことは
答えがない通りに取り組みましょうということなんです
なんで答えのない問いに取り組むことが大事なんでしょうか
答えのある遠いと比べて考えてみたいと思います
答えのある遠いというのは私たちが長年経験してきた
受験勉強のようなものです
私たちが答えノ知っているようなとについて取り組んできました
一方で答えがないといいというのは研究のようなものです
研究は私たちがいまだ発見されていないことや
まだわからないこと答えのないものについて取り組みますよね
研究のプロセスの中で私たちは人と出会い話を聞き
資料を集めたりさらには自分の情報を発信するためにプレゼンテーション子があったり
します
実社会でも例えば新企画の提案をしなければならないといったときにはそれは答えの
ない問いへの挑戦と同じようなことではないでしょうか
ですからみなさんも積極的に答えのない問いチャレンジしてくださいと言いたいわけな
んですが
現場はどうでしょう
私は大学に入って歩こう切って
教授が私たちに君は大学1回生ではない
高校4年生だと言われたことを思い出します
確かにそうかもしれません
本来大学というのは研究機関で答えのないというを探し求める
ところなはずなんです
しかし私たちはまだ高校で培ってきた
受験のための勉強すなわち答えのあるといえの勉強から抜け出せていないのかもしれ
ません
だからこそ今日は私は答えのない当院取り組む
楽しさとそしてその重要性を話しに来ました
といっても私も初めから答えのない当院取り組むのが
大切だとはわかっていませんでした
私もほとんど皆さんと同じように受験をしてきましたし
中学校を選ぶ際も偏差値の高い中学校を選びました
それは私の頭の中でいい中学校に入ればいい高校に入れていい大学に入れてそして良い
就職月につける
そういうひとつのレールのようなものが私の頭の中にあったからです
しかしその考えは
中学校の頃に覆されます
それは
ファーそれ v リーグとの出会いでした
私は中学生の頃にファーストレグリーグという大会にいろいました
ファーそれ v リーグというのは国際的なロボットコンテストで世界的に有名です
もしかしたら皆さんロボットコンテストと聞く聞かれると nhk ロボコンのような
ものを想像されるかもしれませんがパーそれ v リーグはそれに劣らずもっと画期的
でそしてもっと
世界中の人々が集まる楽しい大会なんです
今大会はロボットコンテストといわれますが実はロボットだけじゃないんです
ロボットを使って動かして協議をするだけではなくて実はもう一つ自分の研究の成果を
発表する
プレゼンテーション部門が存在します
これが私のいう答えのない問いに挑戦することの重要性を気付かされた
原点と言ってもいいのです
研究内容は非常にシンプルでお題に添っていれば
自由なんですねで自分で課題を設定し
そしてそれで解決策を導くそれが一連の流れでした
私が参加した年のお題は名 cheers フュリー
自然の猛威でした
皆さん自然の猛威と聞かれると何を想像されますか
たとえば地震であったり津波であったり
台風であったり土砂災害であったりそういう自然災害の減少をもしかしたら頭の中で
想像されるかもしれません
しかしその中で私たちは
防災教育子供のための防災教育に視点を向けて
そして課題として今の子供のための防災教育の不備を設定し
快慶作として防災教育の教材を開発しようとしたんです
私たちはチーム一丸となって自分たちが作る教材が必要となるだろうと信じて活動して
いました
もしファーストレゴリーグという大会が答えのない問いではなく答えのある遠いをお題
にしたらどうしたのかと考えてみることがあります
そうするとまず私たちのチームのように意見のぶつかり合いは起こらなかったと思うん
です
なぜなら答えのあるトイレあればいくら意見も大切だとといえども
その意見は正しいか正しくないかの二つに分かれてしまいます正しくない兄にわざわざ
耳を傾ける必要はないんですね
そしてもう一つそれはたくさんの面白いアイディアにはふれあいなかったんだろうなと
思います
実は私はこのファーそれ v リーグという大会で世界大会に出場しています
世界中の人々と競い合うわけなんですけども
日本とは違って国や文化の違いもあって本当に多様なアイデアが聞くことができました
私は英語という壁を乗り越えて積極的にコミュニケーションを取り
自分たちのチームと意見交換をしたり連絡先を交換して
いまでもその海外のこと連絡を取り合うことがあります
俯瞰して見てみるとこの1つの答えのない問いへの挑戦が
意見のぶつかり合いを引き起こしそして人との交流まで生み出しました
そして何よりこれが楽しいと気づけたのです
ファーストレグリーグに参加する前は
私も受験で知識を詰め込む毎日でした
毎日毎日センス貼られて勉強したのを覚えています
しかし
実際はどうなんでしょう
その縛られるひもを緩めて自分のできることや好きなことや
没頭できることに時間を割いてみるのもいいのではないかと私は思っているんです
私はプレゼンテーションや人前で話すことが好きだから
ファーそれ v リーグという大会に没頭できたのかもしれません
しかしプレゼンテーションやロボットに限った話ではなくスポーツでも同じことが言え
ます
スポーツもどうやったら足の試合に勝てるかなんていう方程式はありません
野球でも旋回村主すれば
うまくなるか明日の試合に勝てるのかといったらそうじゃないかもしれないんです
まず課題を見つけて
自分の弱いところを他人と比較しながら自己分析をする
そして回検索として先輩やコーチの話を聞きながら自分の練習方法を確立していく
確立した自分の練習方法を信じて貫いて次の試合に備えることぐらいしかできない
でしょ
そういう意味でスポーツマンというのは常に答えのない問いに取り組んでいる人と
言えるんです
初めは答えのない当院取り組む際
何が解決策なのかよくわからなくなりますそして不安になります
野球でも走り込みや筋トレをしたからといってすぐに実を結ぶものではありません
答えのない問いを取り組むサイモン
なかなかすぐに答えが出てこないその曖昧さに耐える訓練も必要なんです
今現在嬉しいことにファーストで v リーグのような取り組みが学校現場でも採用さ
れ始めています
それは ssh や sgh などがその例にあたります
特に ssh はスーパーサイエンスハイスクールの略で
高校生のうちから理系の研究ができる環境が整い始めました
しかし
西誠一という研究とはいえどもやはり
研究の結果だけにフォーカスするというような風潮があります
しかし本当に大切なことはそうじゃないと私は言いたいのです
そう大切なことは実はこれもファーそれ v リーグという大会に参加して気づかされ
ました
ファーそれ v リーグにはコアバリューというようなプレゼンテーション教授があり
ます
日本語に訳すとこうあ各バリューが勝ち
核となる価値です
ファーそれ v リーグで最も対戦されているプレゼンテーション競技の一つなんです
けども
ここではチームワークについて競い合います
自分のチームで問題が発生したときにどのようにして解決しましたかというものをお話
するんです
ここで私が言いたいのは研究の結果だけじゃなくて重要なのはそのプロセスなんだと
そこに至るまでのプロセスが大事で
そしてそれはまさに答えのない問いだということです
チームワークに関してはまさに答えがない典型だと思います
私もリーダーを務めたことがあって中学生のころはよく本屋さんに行って
自己啓発の本を読みあさりました
自分はどうやったら10人のチームメンバーをまとめるんだろう
リーダーって何なんだろうということを考えさせられました
本を読んでみるのはいいんですけども著者によって考え方が違うんですね
だから自分でもどうすればいいんだろうって考えて心もや見かけることもありました
ズバリまさにこれが答えのない問いだったんです
私たちは
社会に出るための準備として学校に通います
しかし本当に必要な学習というのは実は机の上で収まりきらないんじゃないでしょうか
それに一刻も早く築ければ自分の興味のあることや好きなことに没頭してそして研究を
して取り組んでみる
そういうだけでもまた違う今とは違う世界を楽しめるはずなんです
私が答えのない当院取り組み始めてもう一つ気づいたことがあります
それは自分を信じることです
私は答えのない遠いへの挑戦として
プロジェクションマッピングという映像技術の研究を行いました
プロジェクションマッピングはコードの映像技術です
私は東京駅のプロジェクションマッピングを見たときにぜひ自分の手でこの
プロジェクションマッピングをつくってみたいと思ったんですね
当時のプロジェクションマッピングは
お客さんを楽しませるエンターテイメント中心のものが多かったのです
ですから私はそうではなくて何か教育用の教材として作れないかなと
プロジェクションマッピングを利用できないかなと考えたんです
その時ふと頭に思い浮かんだのは小学校や中学校のこの学んだ
体の授業でした
体の授業の際に私たちの先生は人体模型を使っていたのですが
人体木を使うよりプロジェクションマッピングという映像 q 2を使って心臓の
リアルな動きであったり
結果の動きであったり神経の流れであったりそういうことを再現できれば子供もっと
楽しめる授業になるのではないかと考えて研究を始めました
しかし
大きな壁にぶち当たったんです
基本中の基本なのですが体に移すための映像のサザエを見つけることができなかったん
です
いくら動画サイトは探ってもなかなかリアルな心臓の動きを見つけることができなかっ
た
そこで私は神戸大学の教授とアポを取り
facebook でつながってそして実際に神戸大学に出向き
映像の素材を得れました
そこで何もかもうまくいったように思えたんです
映像の備えもゲットできたことですし
けど実際はそうではありませんでした
それがの研究はなかなかうまく進むことがなかったんです
なぜ
研究がうまくいかなかったんでしょうか
それは
私は答えを探し求めるあまり自分の個性を活かしきれていなかったんです
リアルな映像技術がなかったらなかったで
もっと自分にできることを考えてみるべきでした
答えがない当院取り組む中でも大事なことはそれは私がこの経験を通して感じた
置かれた状況でいかにして自分の個性を生かすか
自分で解決策を導くか
答えを探し求めるだけではいけないということです
答えのない問いに取り組むのは時にリスクを背負うことになりますし
答えがないからこそ不安になり答えを探しがちになりますが
探すのではなくて自分の力や脳へ培ってきた個性を信じて自分だけのオリジナルを作る
そういった意識が必要なのです
実際私の進退のマッピングはうまくいくことはありませんでした
しかし
だからと言って諦めずに原点に立ち返ってみることにしたんです
進退のマッピングよりより規模の小さいマッピングを作ることにしました
その中でも私が大事にしたのは自分だけのオリジナルの作品を作るという意識です
今ではその努力が実り社会貢献をすることができています
これは福祉関連のオフィスデー
実際に子どもたち障害を持った子供たちに楽しんでもらったプロジェクション
マッピングの一部です
私はファーストで v リーグで学んできた答えのないとに取り組む大切さを
プロジェクションマッピングの研究でも実感してきたわけですが
答えのない問いに取り組むことの真骨頂は
自分の可能性を広げることにあるのだと考えています
自分にできることはきっと大きいことができません
しかし小さいことでもいいから何か課題設定をしてみて
解決策を導いてみ
私の研究もマッピングだけにとどまらず
ロボットの講習会を行い一人でも多くの子どもたちにファーそれ v リーグのような
経験をしてもらいたい
そして答えのない問いへの大切さを知ってもらいたいと考えています
大きなことでなくても小さなことから積み上げてみませんか
皆さんもぜひ答えないと家の挑戦をしみてはいかがでしょうか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]